[Music]
so you're competitive obviously we raced
against each other you're ultra
competitive and you get super sonic
pissed off when you when when things
don't go danica's way that's i like that
the most about you
you come to the team and and you know
you're this little girl and and you're
stronger you have a really strong
personality kind of intimidating at
times and you're like is she gonna hit
me if i do something you would you were
14
and out there and you were just as
spunky as as your whole that was the
beginning of seeing like you turn into
like yeah go get a girl you know
how many times i tell you you can't go
out drinking because you were hard on me
yeah because i knew in the long run
what was what was your first big sponsor
what they do
they went back and checked your record
and would they find dad you just had
speeding tickets that's right up high
because speeding tickets qualify me for
a job in a race car yeah because you
guys became the tricksters and i always
got to ask like what did they do to you
did they like haze you in any way i'm
like i'm not sure they knew what to do
with me now we were too scared
of me or doing the wrong
but also
we got told that you know remember boys
are boys and i know nowadays you i know
you wait a minute you guys get your
wings clipped you can totally take it
but we're like guys you have to like
don't you can do stuff for to her but do
not exaggerate the way you guys do
before her toilet yeah so
you got to take my role for the clips of
swearing then you got to take it over
from me on that what is that called
after the nascar weekends
radioactive yes i always heard from uh
uh ricky when we used to date like that
he hated me swearing and i was on
radioactive all the time apparently
swearing i didn't really listen to him
but i heard i made i made the cut most
of the time
so i'm so glad that they found you and
chad that you could um fill in that gap
yes yes i'm glad to take over for you it
means we have a very
interesting vocabulary i believe
well i don't even what was i like i
don't know well
what i remember most was you kind of you
you were shy-ish
right in the beginning like you were you
were i guess you were probably a little
with with them mostly but probably a
little star struck and kind of like oh
my god they're here that's kind of weird
it was but it was always that right it
was always a bit of the you know
why are they here right like yeah that's
a very much the question why are you
here what are you doing
crossing that doesn't make sense to
people right
um
but you but but like because we were all
together in that tent we we would go out
and watch all the other races and i
remember watching you in one of the
races and going oh she can drive
like she's got that fire and i think
when you would come back in we were you
know we were like dude girl that was
awesome and you were kind of like yeah
whatever and it was like you had like it
wasn't
it wasn't a good race but we were
impressed by it okay and
but that but that's where you like for
me
you gain the respect because it no
longer mattered that we were who we were
you were like i didn't have the race
that i wanted
it didn't matter who else is around
right right it wasn't like i was like
thanks that's really i was like whatever
yeah you were like
the race didn't didn't go
exactly as we planned it you watch i'm
like i probably was like did you watch
the race did you see what i'd i i yeah
of course
right it was like but to us it was like
you know you were an attractive female
recently you just said it if you're out
with the young engineers you guys are
dating
automatic you know and the worst thing
about racing is how tight a circle that
is and it's like literally oh my god
heavens forbid if you even get caught
talking to somebody like it's it's on
it's done it's official you might as
well put it to record books they're
they're full on dating and and that's
just the way it is so i couldn't imagine
them doing you know what you did all
those years being you know the female
that you were and ultimately it was you
know a pretty male dominant sport the
situation do you remember
um
one time i was disappointed i was
disappointed that was my
the way i think about it you and dan had
a bit of an argument
at milwaukee milwaukee
oh yeah yeah i do i
i was uh going into turn one and he sort
of chopped down on me and put me like i
ended up get bumping like we touched and
i went which anybody that knows open
wheel racing you don't really want to
touch wheels i'm and i'm in the grass
going across the grass and one and two i
i come back on and anyway i was i was
having a great race because i think i'd
started like last the car was so so hard
to drive and didn't qualify well and
then i'd made it up to like i was
passing for fifth i feel like on dan in
the first stint which is about 80 laps
and um
so i was hauling
and uh he did that and then it obviously
ended up getting going all the way to
the back again and i think i maybe end
up finishing fifth or eighth or
something like that i came back through
but not you know all the way and um
and afterwards i was so mad at him and
so i talked to my team and then i saw
him on pit lane and you know how it is
that the race track you don't
always have an opportunity to see
someone after the race like because you
ever everybody gets done and then they
leave
yeah and so i saw him and i was like oh
i'm gonna go over there i think i'm
maybe i even asked it reminds me of the
milka dunno situation at um mid-ohio i i
a lot of times ask first like can i go
talk to him like i want to go tell him
who did you out he really nobody really
tells me no and so i go over there and i
put my arm around his
around his shoulder or on his trap and
i'm squeezing his traps so hard and i'm
telling him what he did to me
and i'm so angry and then you know
that's sort of like the the moment and
um
he i remember he kind of spoke down to
me a little he acted like i was
overreacting and
um you know maybe i was but um you know
it was a little condescending
yeah from my point i was watching that i
remember i think i was back at the truck
already or somewhere and i walked or i
watched a replay and i was like that was
the one time i was kind of like you know
what
i think i said to you afterwards i said
if that could have been me or tony
talking and doing that with danny to
punch this
but you put him in a position you were
giving it to him absolutely just
and he he couldn't react
and that was the one time i was like
you know what i mean
so what am i so have you ever been in a
situation with a driver where it where
you were like that angry
[Music]
um oh yeah
so then what happened
um
we
exchanged pleasantries
um
but
but we didn't i'm saying like should i
have been able to do that are you saying
that this is like why it was you i think
if i remember you were actually sort of
giving them a bit of pushing and stuff
as well
yeah and i was like well that was the
difference because if i had to push dw
like that
he would have
which we did have a moment
you know seven we had a bit of an
altercation but um
yeah so
that was the only thing but apart from
that
to
you whether you were teammates or on
track it was
from that moment in india was like yeah
you just you're one of the one of the
drivers one of the
um
yeah
and then uh you know then you you you
just like you're
you used to get fiery so we're like we
backed off we're like
do you feel like i've tamed down a
little bit am i more calm than i than i
was when you remember meeting me and in
the beginning no i could no just about
different things right i think you've
learned how to control yourself a little
more obviously as
years goes by i think you've learned but
also you know nowadays
you probably know that a lot better than
me once you're in the spotlight you got
to unfortunately think about three times
once before you really react and i think
back in the days the good part was
you didn't care you didn't like
something yeah
you're gonna go after that well i mean i
used to i did used to i mean i used to
fly off the handlebars all the time i
remember the one time i was walking down
pit lane the race was still going on it
was michigan we were delayed for like
three hours because of the rain and then
all of a sudden it was drivers to your
cars and we were green flagging 15 laps
and it was the second longest race of
the year next to the indy 500 and um i i
think we sat in the car for 45 minutes
before we even rolled off because they
were still trying to dry weepers and i
wasn't brave enough to get out and go to
the bathroom because i thought sure
enough they're going to
call us to go and um but anyway um and i
remember i i think i ran out of gas like
six laps to go and i was so pissed off
and i was like throwing my helmet down
my earpiece is down i'm walking out
mid-lane and i kick a barrel and the
barrel was empty and i thought it was
full of water and i was like oh [ __ ] and
i picked the barrel up and i stood it up
straight cause i was like oh no but i
mean like i said you probably would do
differently today so i think maybe you
haven't changed maybe i mean i don't
think you have
maybe you're fun to fun to keep up with
a little challenging to keep up with but
um well we're always we're always
thinking about you oh thanks thanks well
i'll have to bring some bring some wine
around i make quite a bit of it now so
we'd love to try oh my gosh i'm having
flashbacks to that
party
a few oh no oh the boat was really fun
too i was actually just reminiscing
about the boat one where amy and myself
and a couple other girls we were like in
we were so hammered and we were oh yeah
it was raining and we were all like
standing in the rain at the front of the
boat but i was also remembering being in
your backyard and having a party in the
backyard and we drank way too much
i don't even remember and you have like
a fun boomerang picture of us in the
backyard many two too many way too many
drinks i know i felt that the next day
but um
you know i know there's more
responsibilities now with kids and
things like that but that doesn't mean
we don't know how to have fun
we know how to have fun if we need to
you're not big enough to be an offensive
lineman anika this is my story you asked
a question
you